how much do you know about black holes
what would happen if you fell into one
say one day you were exploring space
looking for a new planet for humans to
inhabit but came across a black hole and
decided why not check it out would you
have any chance of survival how would
you get out would there be a shortcut to
another universe this is what if and
here's what would happen if you fell
into a black hole
despite being black and a hole a black
hole is not a dark empty space in his
theory of relativity Einstein predicted
how black holes are formed when a
massive star dies it leaves a smaller
remnant core behind if the cores mass is
at least three times bigger than the
mass of our Sun gravity overwhelms all
other forces and turns the core into a
black hole but don't let its name fool
you a black hole isn't a hole at all but
rather a huge amount of matter packed
into a very small space think of the Sun
with its gravitational field 28 times
stronger than Earth's if you were to
walk on the Sun you'd be 28 times
heavier than you are on earth now
imagine squeezing four Suns into
something that's just 15 miles in
diameter the distance you can cover in a
30-minute Drive
what would the gravity be like there a
black hole's gravity is so strong that
even light can't get out that's why
you'll never see one but you can detect
it from the gamma-ray bursts to the hole
emits these bursts discovered by Stephen
Hawking now carry his name Hawking
radiation Stephen Hawking himself
believed that black holes can be
passages to another universe so if you
were to fall into one would you find
yourself in an alternate dimension every
black hole has an event horizon the
point at which gravitational pull
becomes so strong you can't escape from
it
the point of no return if you found
yourself outside of that point you'd see
that stars are twisted around a perfect
circle of darkness as you start being
pulled toward a black hole you'd be
moving faster and faster accelerated by
the force of gravity that's the first
bad news for you brave space traveler
the gravitational force of a black hole
is very very strong if you fell feet
first your legs would be feeling a
stronger gravitational pull than your
head your body would be stretched apart
the most common black holes are called
stellar they can stretch about 9 miles
across and be as heavy as 20 Suns if you
happen to be pulled towards a stellar
black hole you'd be completely torn
apart before you even reach the event
horizon so make sure to choose a
supermassive one the one that's a
million times heavier than our Sun in
this case your body would remain
unharmed as you cross the event horizon
as the gravity would be pulling both
your feet and your head with almost the
same strength and if you're wondering
where to find one you don't have to look
too far there's one right at the center
of our Milky Way galaxy luckily it's a
hundred and sixty-five quadrillion miles
away from us and will suck in neither
the Sun nor the planets but don't pack
your suitcase just yet crossing the
event horizon is just the beginning of
the challenge there's a gravitational
singularity at the center of the black
hole where density becomes infinite
you'd be squashed into that center and
become one with the black hole you
wouldn't be able to tell anyone about
your experience however a person
observing you from outside the event
horizon would see a very different
picture as you were falling into a black
hole they'd see you slowing down getting
dimmer and redder in the end you just
freeze never crossing the event horizon
this is because space and time in a
black hole swapped the roles at the
event horizon time comes to a standstill
while space on the other hand moves
forward you wouldn't be able to turn
around and escape the black hole any
more than you could travel back in time
even when the black hole eventually died
emitting all the particles it had
absorbed including your body it would be
impossible to tell whether those
particles were you Stephen Hawking
however found a way in which the
information about your body wouldn't be
lost he theorized that there are
alternative universes with different
histories this means in one reality you
fell into a black hole in the second one
there was no black hole it's impossible
to be certain from outside of the event
horizon whether there's a black hole or
not until you fall in there if you cross
the event horizon and there was a black
hole sayonara
but if you happen to be in a reality
where the black hole didn't exist you'd
still be alive
just in a different universe there would
be no way for you to get back to ours
would you dare explore the possibility
are you drawn to black holes in the
universe
very soon we'll take you on your next
hypothetical adventure
[Music]